So, to answer a question like this, it helps to draw a class diagram. So, we
have class A, which base class is B. And the way this is typically drawn is to
show an arrow pointing up from the derived class to the base class. Now, we have
class C inheriting from A and class D also inheriting from A. And then, we have
class E inheriting from D. So now, it's easy to answer our questions. So, the
question. What the subclasses of A is, is any class where you can follow these
arrows up and reach A so the direct subclasses are C and D. E is also a subclass
of A. The second question, what are the superclasses of E? And that would be
the, any class we can reach starting from E following the arrows up. And there's
one more, which you would get a bonus if you got this as well, which is the
object class that's built in. We don't know anything else about B. It may have
other superclasses, but we know it must have object as one of it's superclasses
because all classes we define in Python eventually reach the object class.
Finally, which class is inherit from D? There, it's only one class, which is
class E.